sometimes in films I'll see a scene
between two people where one person
knows something's wrong and they want to
kind of be the hey how's it going and
everybody's trying to make nice and it
feels forced when we realize there's a
problem underneath the surface and it
just hasn't come out yet
so character a is trying to get
character B to admit that there's some
type of a problem ooh
that's a weird specific one yeah but I
see it and it's it's this has to do with
what Roger Ebert used to call the idiot
plot where the thing is if two
characters just said what they know to
each other the movie would be over in
five seconds and so basically what it is
is you have a character that is being
forced by the writer not by not by in
real life and real life they would say
something but the the if the writer
realizes if they say it the movies over
in five minutes or now this thing goes
in a different direction so they don't
say those things they keep them to
themselves which place false instead we
want to do is we want to have D and this
is this is the thing often people
they're afraid to create the conflict
because the conflict gets into the messy
stuff and so they hold back on the
conflict when we need to get into that
conflict they there's a thing that
another another screenwriting problem is
delaying things because we you know will
that conflict really can't happen until
this point or at this point sorry camera
this point in the movie when we're at
this point
well what usually happens is they they
stall until they get to that conflict
when instead what they should do is have
that conflict happen here and then have
things just continue to get worse
so that scene here instead of being the
you know the the the beginning of the
conflict instead is when the conflicts a
hell of a lot worse they don't escalate
their conflict enough an escalating
conflict is important again it's an in
dialogue it would seem false if that
character didn't say there's a problem
and here's what it is or you know I have
an issue with you and they need to have
that issue it needs to be it needs to
start here
you know the fuse needs to not just be
lit but then it needs to explode and
that explosion has to start a chain
reaction of other explosions so that's
it's like an act to problem often is
writers try to not try to hold
everything off until act two when you
need to kick off with you know with
something exciting happening I there's a
thing I call the golfing goat rule where
if your movie is about a farmer with a
goat that learns how to golf and you
know plays in the PGA you can't hold the
secret of the goat golfing until page 25
because the poster shows dirty the
golfing goat there's the trailer that
shows the goat golfing against Tiger
Woods all that stuff is given away to
the audience so you can't hold that back
instead you've got to basically hit the
ground running with the goat golfing and
from there it's you go well that that
has to happen deep in the story well
that only has to happen deep in the
story if then nothing much happens
instead you need to have that happen
upfront and then keep escalating the
golfing until you know till I don't know
the goats golfing with the president I
have no idea
you